MAATTA HAS BEEN THE BEST
PLUS-MINUS PLAYER FOR TESSARILY
SCORE OOP A WRIST WRIST SHOT
OUT OF PLAY.
>> TH WHERE THEY
COLEMAN PREVENTING A 2K3WR5EUD A
LOOK.
E IS REALLY SLOWED
DOWN HERE IN THE FIRST PERIOD.
IT WAS VERY AROUND AND
WAIT FOR THE GAME TO COME TO
THEM BECAUSE OF HOW STI RETURN
PASS FOR KOPITAR
CHANCES.
KALIY
CRITICAL.
EVERYTHING SO POSITIVELY, IT SH.
WATCH THE SPEED ON ATTACK THE CR
BY THE MUCHPARATION THEN I THING
ONE WAY AND SNAPPING THE WRIST
THEORNER.
DONE UP TOP NICE PLAY BY IAFALLO
AS HETH THE
GOODS.
>> HE CERTAINLY DOES HERE.
HE SMO
KALIYEV UP ICE.
DONSKOI.
RIGHT WING.
STOPS SNAP.
>> FIRED IN ON A
DEPLAYED -- DELAYED OFF SIDE.
BJORNFOT RUNS
FRONT.
EN.
DURZI FOR VERY SIMPLE I THINK TE
KINGS BODY POSITION IN FRONT OR
T NEARLY BOUGHT
IT ONE FROM TWO FEET OUT.. ALLO.
DURR DURZI DID A ALD AND GEEKIEE
BOX.
>> WEEL VERY WHAT HAPPENS L L HL
SHIFTS.
IT PUTS A